weather
[Musique]
wafa
/
à
ouais
oh
voilà
[Musique]
m
waouh
[Musique]
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin du
world big n 3 a alors je voulais quand
même vous dire quelques mots à la fin de
la vidéo déjà j'ai reçu honnêtement je
dirais 300 ou 400 messages sur ma boite
mail d'or et 300 je dirais et puis bas
âge le temps de tout télécharger ça a
pris pas mal de temps c'est pour ça que
je vous sors cette vidéo que maintenant
même le montage aussi après quand même
pas mal de temps alors je voulais
m'excuser s'il y en a qui m'envoyaient
des oiseaux que je n'ai pas pris ça peut
être soit par erreur soit parce que la
qualité de la vidéo était vraiment trop
trop trop mauvaise dans le sens où il y
avait trop de pixels et c'est donc voilà
je m'excuse d'avancé pour cela en tout
cas ça m'a fait vraiment plaisir de voir
que vous étiez autant à vous investir
comme ça à répondre un peu à cette vidéo
que j'avais fait sur une couche sur une
idée qu'il m'était venue et recevoir
comme ça autant de messages
franchement je m'y attendais pas je vais
attendais pas mais ça montre que voilà
la us family on a un peu tous soudés et
tout et ça fait vraiment plaisir de voir
qu'autant de gens s'investissent y en a
même qui ont fait des trucs vraiment
ultra originaux par exemple cet homme
qui s'écrase 1,9 sur la tête endommagé
on va râler ou chérie qui remue ses
grosses fesses bien grasse franchement
il était vraiment super j'ai même
regardé toutes vos vidéos en entière
parce que vous êtes vraiment nombreux
avoir fait des montages c'est-à-dire à
avoir fait vous même la transition entre
les wasaï rwasa oise avoir fait un petit
mot à la fin pour mes trois cent mille
et caetera et je peux vous promettre que
j'ai prétendu tout regarder il y avait
par exemple en mars et y est calé en
haut de la colline juste à côté de chez
lui il y avait une [ __ ] de vue super
génial dans vantons sionisme sur lui un
jeu le mettre à l'écran là par exemple
il y avait aussi des canadiens des
québécois vraiment plein de messages de
soutien qui veut un peu de partout
et enfin je veux dire que quand vous
voyez autant de gens qui vous répondent
qu'ils s'investissent et qui qui se font
chier à faire un truc vraiment original
et sympa ou même un truc simple mais
quand même à le faire ça fait vraiment
très très plaisir et et voilà encore une
fois je vous suis vraiment mille fois
reconnaissant je vous remercie vraiment
pour votre investissement à tous et à
toutes
quand même des filles qui sont apparus
quelques fois et puis voilà écoute et
j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu
et si vous voulez d'autres even comme ça
où je vous fais tous participé ou quoi
n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo et j'ai
déjà une petite idée en tête d'ailleurs
bref on verra ça et puis voilà je
voulais sur mes deux dernières vidéos
franchement ça m'a fait vraiment chaud
au coeur et puis je vis à la prochaine
by piece
[Musique]
ma
[Applaudissements]